l'entrée de montchanin le rond point
jeanne rose pendant 17 mois
chaque samedi les gilet jaune s'y sont
rassemblés sans discontinuer c'est l'un
des derniers bastions de ce mouvement
contestataire en saône et loire
on continuera le combat parce que on
peut pas nous le peuple il est il est
dans la misère
un mouvement qui restait pacifique sur
la commune mais qui a marqué le bassin
minier
ces revendications des gilet jaune les
deux candidats à la mairie de montchanin
les connaissent bien
jean yves vernochet le maire sortant ou
son opposant frédéric marasiah les
entendent souvent auprès dé mon chat ni
noah surtout celles concernant le
pouvoir d'achat
forcément les montchaninois sont aussi
touchés par cette baisse du pouvoir
d'achat qu'on ne peut on ne peut pas
contester donc dans notre programme
on a intégré un certain nombre de choses
pour aider les habitants sur ce sujet là
alors en direct c'est le gel de la
fiscalité le les habitants ne doit pas
être la variable d'ajustement pour
régler des problèmes budgétaires dans
une collectivité
mais pour le maire sortant ses
revendications ne peuvent pas être
complètement solutionner à l'échelle
d'une ville on a toujours gardé ça d'un
oeil d'un oeil attentif en se disant
quelles sont les véritables
revendications
on voyait vraiment c'était des
revendications d'un niveau national je
pense qu'ils ont toujours trouvé une
écoute auprès de nos centres communaux
d'action sociale
on a aussi mis en place les locaux pour
les restos du coeur pour le secours
populaire pour pouvoir les accueillir
les aider on est toujours à aller coûte
jean yves vernochet revendique un
programme de gauche si dans sa liste le
maire sortant n'a aucun gilet jaune
c'est que l'opportunité ne s'est pas
présenté l'occasion s'est pas trouvée
puisque les lois sur une autre liste
justement un tel mélange dans cette
liste qui savent est un peu compliquée à
gérer derrière mais ça c'est le sait le
problème de
de mon challenger mais pour son rival
frédéric marasiah sans étiquette
la présence d'une gilet jaune sur sa
liste est au contraire une façon de
renouer avec une partie de la population
c'est vraiment ça qui est qui est le
plus important je pense l'écoutent la
proximité et pouvoir régler des
problèmes au quotidien sans attendre que
ceux-ci s'envenimer deviennent à un
problème plus important
les deux candidats proposent tous deux
de renforcer l'accueil des nouveaux
arrivants et le retour de service public
disparu de la commune reste que
montchanin peine à profiter de la
proximité du creusot et de montceau la
population diminue depuis plusieurs
années et au dernier recensement
dépassaient tout juste les 5000
habitants